welcome to this bun crash course bun is
a cuttingedge toolkit designed to
supercharge your JavaScript and
typescript applications with its
Lightning Fast startup times built in
support for typescript and jsx and a
range of powerful features designed to
seamlessly replace node.js bun promises
to revolutionize your development
experience whether you're looking to
optimize serverless functions or enhance
your workflow this course will Empower
you to leverage Bun's full potential and
seamlessly integrate it into your
projects hder Malik developed this
course he is a full stack developer and
entrepreneur bun is a JavaScript runtime
it's a similar or alternative of nodejs
but it but it is faster than node.js you
can execute JavaScript and typescript
with one you can also install the
packages with the help of bun it will
also have provide function ality to run
test cases you will have all in one
toolkit you can develop test run and
bundle JavaScript and typescript
projects that is the definition of
bun it can execute JavaScript and
typescript on the server it will also
compatible with nodejs package
manager under the hood it's a Javas
script run time it helps to run
JavaScript similarly in the Chrome you
can run
JavaScript let's do that here I'm going
to run the
JavaScript I can
say y a z is equal to
10 let me print Z I got the value so I
can run JavaScript on the Chrome browser
bun can run JavaScript on the server
side bun is a new JavaScript runtime
built from scratch to serve the modern
JavaScript
ecosystem the reasons to use burn it's
faster burn starts fast and runs fast it
extends JavaScript core the performance
minded JS engine built for
Safari it also provide the API key API
for like starting an HTTP server and
writing
files bun is designed as a drop-in
replacement for node.js it natively
implements hundreds of nodejs and web
apis including FS path and
buffer the goal of the bun is to run
most of the World server side JavaScript
alternative to nodejs and provide tools
to improve performance reduce complexity
and multiply developer
productivity you can also use external
nodejs packages with with bur you can
also execute typescript fast fast
running
performance web standard apis you can
also run TSX like typescript with
react works with node modules no more
module Madness you can also use the
watch mode run test in the watch mode
starting an HTTP server websocket server
read and write hash password write a
test this is the result they got Benn is
BN took 36 seconds PNP took more
seconds and npm took more
seconds 36 second here and yarn is a bit
slower Nots compatible crazy fast Let's
test it how burn is fast this is a test
result of a burn burn is also a test
Runner you can also run test with the
help of burn just like you did with just
framework just compatible syntax crazy
fast enough Theory now we're going to
install the burn on our
machine
I have a
Mac I can install the burn by using this
one if you are
windows you can also install
burn if you are windows you can use this
option
I am on the
Mac I'm going to install
burn if you want to install specific
version you can do that but I'm going to
install
the current version or the latest
version
bun was installed successfully let's
check it
out if I write
burn Das Das
help to get started you got to run this
one this
[Music]
command now I can run bur Das D help it
can recognize the command oh my God it
took it took a few seconds to install
the bun burn run run J JavaScript a
package.json file or a script run unit
test you can use this command if you
want to run in a depal mode you can do
this command if you want to in create an
empty project you can use this one if
you want to create a next GS project you
can use this command if you have to
install any dependency you can use burn
I or add a dependency bu a or bun add
remove dependency bun
RM link link and npm globally you can
use Link PM more commands for managing
packages BN build build bundle
typescript and JavaScript into a single
file upgrade to the latest version you
can use this
command we have installed burn
successfully now we're going to create a
new project burn project
let's create a new folder I can say in
my code file in my code
folder you can say burn
first oh make directory burn
first let's go to the burn first
let's create a new project by using bun
in
[Music]
it you can provide your package name I
can use bur first entry file should be
index.ts
file please run that so it has also
executed the
file so I'm going to open the code into
my visual studio code
editor
oh oh my God I got the node modules
folder inside the node modules I got the
bun
types we have the package.json file TS
config
file so I got the node modules bun lock
file I cannot see that we have the
index.ts file we also have typescript
configuration that's amazing you can run
run the
typescript with the help of burn now
this project is compatible with
typescript you can run any type of
typescript project or any kind of nodejs
project let's say I'm going to run the
node file as a
node let's create a new
function read
do or
read I'm going to take I'm going to
provide the text the string
I'm going to provide the arrow function
and it is going to return hello or
return text I'm just
adding a typescript I can call the
message hello
world and I can print the hello world
here
const text I got the
text or I can say the
message
so I can print the message
here by using the log you can run
typescript I can use this command bun
run to run the typescript
project Bun Run
index.ts that's amazing hello world you
don't need to set up any type of if you
are working with nodejs you have to set
up you have to install depth
dependencies of typescript you have to
do some configuration you don't need to
do that it is automatically compatible
or already configuration conf already
configured with typescript that's
amazing now we're going to move forward
uh I can create a web server with with
the bun let's create a get
repository get in it I'll push that git
repository into a
project get
[Music]
commit first commit setup
burn oh I did not add
that get
commit
[Music]
DM
setup and I can push that code I don't I
think I did not set the repository let's
set the
repository I can say
GitHub let's create a new repository you
can find the source source code at this
repository what I can do I can create a
new branch I can start from here I can
say setup or init I can use the
init burn
course I can say source
code for
bur
YouTube source code for burn course
that's
it
let me push my code it will create the
master BR or main
branch now you should see the main
branch this is the entry
point we have only single branch which
is main which is entry point
you can
start uh you can start checking out this
repository and start with main branch
that's it let's move forward let's
create a new Branch I can say web
server
server web
[Music]
so I'm going to delete everything from
index. let's create a new
server we can use burn.
Serve Port should be
3,000 and fetch should be there's a
fetch method it will take request
argument let's return the
response hello
world that is it it's a simple the
fastest the simple way to create create
a web server that's amazing I like that
listening on
Port
HTTP Local
Host colon and uh I can use back tick
here listening
[Music]
to server I can get the port from here
server. Port that's
it so now we need to run the project I
can run
that I was running the project bur
[Music]
run
index.ts oh it's not a
bin it's a
one
so I got the
issue template string was
not now my server is running at Local
Host colum 3000 I can check that from
Local Host colon
3000 amazing you can see the hello world
message here if I
change
if I change anything hello
world are you
learning
burn but we have to set configure the
automatically uh Auto reloading I didn't
set
that we can also configure a script
for
start I can say bur run index.ts that's
it there is nothing new here npm or you
can run burn instead of npm you don't
need to install external npm I can say
Burns Run start that looks
good so you want to install the package
you can also do that burn add I can I
can add a packet
fidget or F figlet I don't
know bur add it's going to install the
dependency let's add burn a new package
you can also install the typing of the
burn types and fig let oops oops oops
oops fake
let now let's use that package
figlet I can import
figlet from figlet figlet I can see the
suggestion
what I need to do I I need to do a
little bit changing
here
body figet dot text
[Music]
sync
hello
hola instead of response I can provide
the
body in the response let's run the
project
so oh my God so you
can add a little bit changing in the
text or modify the
text I am learning
burn don't worry I'll figure it out how
to run in the development mode
project you can see I am learning
[Music]
burn
if you want to R run the bur in a
development mode or a watch mode you can
add a
script I can say dript
burn Das
dwat I have to provide my entry file
which is index.ts so I can say burn def
bur
runev so my application is running on
listening
mode hello I'm learning
burn from my video oh
nice so I
have I got
that now you can see a simple video that
looks
good so we have created the web server
let's create new routes in the
server inside the fetch I can get the
URL by using
the new
URL it's a it's a function I can get the
URL I can add the logic if url. path
name should be root
URL then you you can return this
response otherwise you can return new
response and I can save
404 I can also add a new check url. path
[Music]
name here let's say I'm going to add a
triple sign strict equal in
JavaScript if we have the about about
page I can say return new
response about me I can rended the HTML
text
here about
me my application is running now
let's look at the root
route I'll get the video if I look at
the about I'll get the about me page
what about the contact page if URL do
path name should
be I can say the
contact return new
response contact us
let's visit the
contact so I can see the contact
as I can create a new Branch it should
be
routes adding
routes and I can push that into
Repository
now I'm going to teach you how to handle
error let's create a new
route path
[Music]
name I'm going to create a new route
which is
feed and this I don't I'm not going to
send any content in the response so I
can return the
error could not
fetch
feed if error comes it is going to throw
the error otherwise it is going to
return the response 404 if I try to
fetch the invalid route I will get the
404 if I try to fetch the FED route I'll
I'll get the I got the error but I want
to I want to render the error in
readable format I don't want to break
the complete application you can do that
here there is an error method it is
going to take the error
argument here I can return the
response so let me render the HTML here
PR and we have to provide the
error and you can also render or log the
eror
tag I'm going to log the eror Stag let
me close the pre- tag so we are
rendering the HTML we have to set the
header for
HTML let me set the content
type let me set it as an
HTML whenever you call this throw method
it is going to call the error method if
error comes it is going to call the
error function this one so I got the
error could not feed error this is the
complete error message and in the new
line it is going to print the error
stack error could not error could not
find could not fetch the
feed in this video I'm going to teach
you how to stream a file in bun let's
create a new file you can use any name
here I'm going to create txt file let's
call it g. txt hello guys
hello bun
developer so now we need to read this
file in the index.ts
file let's create a new
route URL
dot path
[Music]
name should be
create then we need to read this file I
can say new
response 1.
file we need to provide the path of the
file in our case gr.
txt let's look at I'm going to access
the gr
route the path does not exist oh I
forgot to add this back slash
now hello burn
developer uh we have learned the basics
of burn now I'm going to teach you how
can we build a restful
apis uh we have used if you have worked
with
nodejs I'm sure you used expressjs
framework to build rest
apis uh if you want to build rest API in
bun you can use a framework it's built
on the top of BUN and you can use the
typescript typescript supported
supercharge by
bun so it
provides a framework you can see it's a
faster than all of these framework fast
fastify Kaa Express in the nest that is
amazing so 18x faster than Express let's
look
at so we have to install the app let we
I've already installed bun let's create
a new project I'm in the my project
folder if you want to do in in terminal
you can also do that but I have open the
vs code burn create
Alysia and Alysia and I'm going to call
it my application you can use
bndr
API awesome it's going to create a rest
API let me go to the
CD uh to my rest
API and I can open that project into my
vs code editor I'm going to close the
previous code
editor now you can see the index.ts file
we have bulog package.json
file and we have TS config they have
already created a Dev script to run the
project in development
mode and I can see new Alysia doget we
have a root route this is how you can
create a new server that's amazing so
let's run the project burn run
oops
awesome we have created a new server
like in
Express awesome hello Alisia I can
change
that hello
Bund I'm going to
build restful
API
so it has it is listening on the port
3000 so here I have mentioned the host
and the port server Port Lisa is running
at local host and here is our
Port let's look at hello Dev Bev I'm
going to build restful apis this is
amazing
now we're going to talk about routing in
Alicia
Alysia we have already created the get
route we can create a
route by using the chaining let's create
a new
route I'm going to create the get
route this time I would like to
add the V or path parameter let's
say
post and I get the ID so I can get the
prams here I can use the destructuring
here this is a request Handler and it is
going to destructure the prams and I
would like to extract the
ID here I can return anything let's say
if I want to return the ID I can do
that one run
Dev so I would like to test this
route let's try to access the
route Local Host column 3000 SL post ID
I would like to provide the ID which is
one here
so I'm returning the Json object and
here I got the ID you can also do that
let's say it's an ID and I can return
the title learn
burn so now you will
get title and the
ID I also want to talk about let's
complete that get
route or here I can
say
route so we have created the get route
now let's define the post route or
delete route you can also do that let's
say I
post and it's going to get the request
body so I'm going to use the call back
function
it's going to give me the
body let's return something
here so we need to perform the post
request I'm going to use the postman if
you don't have a postman you can install
this software we're going to use this
software to test the
API I have to send the post request
Local Host call in
3000 and/
poost let's provide the body you can
provide the body by going to the raw and
Json ID one title should be Lear
note so I got
request PA
post I don't get the body
we'll talk more about how will you get
the
party so let's create another
route this time I can
say
track everything like when you send
request track SL1 SL track SL anything
it's going to call this method let me
show you the
demo
return track
route Let's test it out I can send the
request I have to send the get
request so I'm going to send the get
request I don't need to provide the
party for the get request track
slash2 I'll get the track rout if I say
track
slash to/
learn I got the track
route whatever you send after this track
matching it's going to call this method
track
route
so we did not talk about the context
object here we
are uh we are getting the prems from the
context object this should be the
context so here I'm going to return the
context
let's add a new
out so I can
send the post
post
out let's provide some
body
ID or title should be learn
anything so I got the
context here I got the
context
so context has request property request
object it's a raw request for accessing
data as a FB standard
type so party which come with request
but I don't I'm not getting any body
here we will I will you will also get
the query prems store which is a global
store is
a uh store is a global mutable
store for Alicia
instance you will also get the set
response
representation I get the status code and
the
header
what about here if I try to get the
body Lia Lysa
follow you use the destructuring
pattern if I do
that let's send the request that looks
good I got the body when I was not using
the destructuring I was using this
one context I'm returning the context in
the
response I was not getting the body
request
body so if you have worked with Express
you have to use a Json middleware you
don't need to use Json middleware here I
can destructure the body and I can
return the body that's it
so now I got the
party let's say
[Music]
description
learning pun from
course so I got description and the
title you can also get the set property
set if you want to set these status code
you can also do that let's
say it's returning a
body it's returning an
object and inside the function let me do
that
here I'm going to
set set do status code let's say if I
set the for 43 it's going to return the
403 status
code you can see the 403 Forbidden but I
want to I want to have 2011 let's say a
record created
successfully now I got 2011 that looks
good
if you want to return the array Json
array you have to stringify that let's
create a new route I can say
tracks so what I want to
do I want to return a new response
here I want to send the Json array so
have we have to
stringify I can say songs or
tracks let's provide a
tracks can say dancing
feed here I can
say whatever song
[Music]
name let's try to fetch all the tracks I
can send the get request let's send the
tracks to fetch all the tracks so I got
this one
tracks but we did not set the header for
the this response type that's why we are
not seeing adjacent
response
so we have to set the
headers here we have to provide the
header content
type it should be application
sljs
now you can see that I can see adjacent
response back
here I got the tracks I have all of
these
tracks one more thing I would like to
mention if you don't want to use json.
stringify Alysia will convert that for
you if you return the simple let me
comment
that if you comment that and if you
return a simple
array Alysia will do that for
you
it's I'm going to return the
array
so that's
it so we have to return the object here
I can say
tracks
and we can close the
object let's send
now I got the same
response let's add a new new
song so I got a new song
here now we're going to talk about how
to build a state
edit now we're going to talk about if
you want to extend the Handler function
you can also do that this is this is
useful when you need to access extra
values in a Handler like database
connection or any variable or any
variable you
need uh I can set the state here
here I can call the state let me Define
the state I can say version one or you
can provide any value
here so I can
also add a decorate it's additional
properties let's say you want to map any
value or you can say get
dat it's a function it's going it's
going to return the date current date
and you can destructure the value here
in your Handler function let's say I
want to
use the date and the state here I can
access the store and I can access the
get dat function you can see
that uh now I can use that I can log the
state let me log the
store and I can log the I can call the
get dat
function or you can call get dat dat
it's returning the date so all I need is
to call all I need to use the get
dat let's try to run the
project my application is running so we
have to fetch all the
tracks I'm going to send the get
request so I got all of these tracks in
here you can see the version and this is
a function so it's returning dat do now
is returning a function so we have we
got to call that function let's do that
I'm going to call this
function let's use
it and I got the exact let's use let's
add more
values so if you want to add a multiple
Properties or you can add the object
here
here a let's
say uh ID should be one
or whatever variable you want to store
here
email should
be let's provide the email
Jan
gmail.com so I have accessed the store
let's say I want to use the I want to
access the I want to access the store
here inside the while creating the post
so I got the store so I can
log the
store let's do
that uh so we going to create a new po
post to access the to log this store so
let me create a new post so here I got
the
store
now we're going to talk about plug-in a
plugin is a way to decouple logic into
smaller parts and defining reusable
components across the
server defining a plugin is as simple as
defining a new Alysia
instance let's create a new
plug-in I'm going to create plugin
inside the index.ts
file
here I'm going to define a
plugin Define
plug-in con
plugin new
Alysia let's define the state for the
plug-in here you can Define plugin
version let's say I'm going to use the
one do
get let's define the
route I can say form
plugin
it's a Handler function and it's just
returning a simple string or let's
define a new method slash
create this simple message hello hello
Dev so we have created a plug-in now we
need to register that plug-in you can
use the use method in the application
instance
here so I would like to register this
plug-in with the help of plugin you can
uh break your code into multiple
components now I have this is a separate
code this is my
application so you can also move that
plug-in into a separate file I'll also
show you how to do that but let's say I
have registered that plug-in now I want
to use that plug-in into my application
how can you do
that you can extract a plug-in from the
store or you can uh use the let's let's
get let's access the the state from the
plug-in you can do
that
so where I want to I want to
get let's
say for in here I want to get access
here in the tracks route
so I would like to
log
the
store and I would like to access the
plug-in version that looks good it's
also giving the syntax highlighting I
have registered the plugin in the
application and inside the plugin I have
defined the route this
one so I have defined the state plug-in
version now we need to call this get
tracks it should
log this uh oh I got the plugin version
here inside the store we got the plugin
version what about these routes let's
let me access these
routes did the did did the application
create these routes so I'm going to copy
that let me paste it let me paste it
here and I'm going to use the create
let's do that oh my God that's amazing
hello def I got the route what about
this this form plugin let me access
that oh God awesome I got the
high so you can uh plugin also
registered these routes so in the
application by using the application
instance you can use these routes these
routes so registering a plug-in will
combine the types between plug-in and a
current instance and the scope of hooks
and schema got merged as well so scope
and the schema get merged here the store
object is merged now you can see
that you can also place a plugin into a
separate file I can I can use plugin. TS
file uh let me move the plug-in
code
here we need to import
Alysia so we also need to export the
plugin so I can use the plugin here let
me import
plug-in plugin that looks good so we got
the
plugin our application still working I
can access these
routes let's say I want to access GRE
route it should give me the
message what about fetching the tracks
it should log the store this plug-in
version that's powerful concept you can
break your application into multiple
components let's say you are building
the Spotify clone you can
create plugin for tracks plug-in for
artists plugin for
users you can divide your application
into
plugins
now now I'm going to talk about how can
you group multiple
routes I've already implemented that
feature you can use the app Group I have
converted listen method into separate
app. listen here I have created a routes
this is a group a user group you can say
if we need to create a new route related
to user you can do it here let's say I
want to define a get route user dot uh
whatever you want to say package let's
say that
org get user by
ID
so it's going to give me the user by ID
so now we need to test this
[Music]
function let's test it out we need to
send the get
request I can send the user and I'm
going to provide the
ID
so I got the user by ID
route you can also make versioning of
your API just like I did here version
one and I can I'm getting the app as an
argument into my Handler function here
I'm defining all of my routes let's
define a new route for a products I can
define a put route
or update
product here I can say update product by
ID we can also
Define delete
route delete product by
ID so this should be the delete
ID so this is how you can group your
routes let's try to access the route V1
products and the
ID so I got the get product by ID what
about the delete one or what about the
update one I got update product by ID
let's try to access delete I got the
delete product by ID this is how you can
group multiple routes into single route
if you want to if you want to add the
validation for your route
Handler Alysia provides a models
approach let's
define a new route actually we have
defined the sign in
route this is a post route so we need to
get the
body for the sign in in the body a user
need need to provide username and the
password we are returning the complete
body or I can say I'm returning the body
dot
[Music]
username I'm returning the object
username body dot actually return the
complete part let's return
that so let's send the signin request
for the user and the signin
here to send the body we need to select
the Json select the raw select
Json and you need to provide the body
here I'm going to provide the username
Jan
gmail.com let's provide the
password 1 2 3 4
5 so I'm getting the the username in the
password back but how can you add the
validation let's say if I send invalid
field anything it will accept I don't
want that we need to add the validations
so in Alysia you need some you need a
model you need to define the type of
your body you want to
accept let me do that
here
here you need to add the
body it's asking me the
body what is T you can get that typing
from thisa they call the T I don't
know this is here you can Define the
type it's like an interface
here and I'm defining the type for the
body so I can say I need to define the
type should be
string
[Music]
and what about the password
field D do
[Music]
string that looks
good
now you can see it will not accept the
invalid let's say if I add
invalid oh I got the I got the error
invalid
body you got to provide the username and
the
password you cannot add any additional
field just like that it's going to give
me the error
here we have validated the request party
it's like a dto data transfer
object what about the
response for the
response I can
say d doob let's define the object
type we would like to send the object or
not the type of the username should be
string and the type of
password should be
string so this is the uh dto or or
typing for the
response if I add now you can see that
so in the response it will send only
username and password
you can also create a separate file and
say models.
TS and you
can use your
models here I'm going to copy
that you need to get the typing
from
Alysia T
lysia let's store into sign in dto I
call it data transfer
object and we can export
that now we can use the model dto here
Here sign in dto call
it sign
in
dto I'm also going to replace this
response object to sign in D to
you
so it's going to fine it's going to
working fine and let me add invalid
field any field I should get the error
so this is how you validate the request
body so I'm returning the ID let's add
the validation for the
[Music]
prams I can use the prms
object let's define the object
type here we need to provide the ID and
and I'm going to use numeric type
let's run the
project this will convert a string into
number
automatically so I'm going to open the
[Music]
postman so we have to send this request
V1 SL products and the
ID we need to send the get request to V1
product and the ID which is
one it's going to return the one ID in
the response if I
provide string and it's a numeric it's
a it's a number so it should give me the
eror invalid pram
ID expected Union
value so if you
provide a b c
d it's going to return me the error if I
provide the
integer it will work so this is how you
will apply the validation on
parameters in this lesson I'm going to
teach you how to build a front Ed
application with
one let's create a new application I'm
going to use as a
v white provides a lot of template for
react View and
angular I'm going to provide the name of
my application I can say
react react
application it will ask me the framework
I'll choose the react whatever front end
application you want to
create let's say I want to create with
react uh I'm going to use typescript
with s swc Speedy web
compiler it it's going to create uh it
it has set up the project for me so I
can do that go to react B
install install all the
dependencies now my project has created
so I'm going to go to my react
app uh I have already in my react app
let me run the
project now I would like to run the
project by using this command let me
open the project in my VSS
code so let's run the
project you can see the project is
running
on Local Host colum
5173 if you want to run the
v as a bun you can change a script here
you can write bun X Das
dasb and
theide
you should see the react project is
running
now I've also modified that script so it
will run the white CLI as a bun not a
nodejs now I'm going to teach you how to
build an HTTP server using Express and
burn so make D make directory Express
with
bun you can choose any
name CD
Express with pun go to this
directory open the open with code
editor I can create a server. TS
[Music]
file let's import Express
I don't need to do any setting for
typescript it will automatically run
it let's create the
[Music]
application we have to set the
port I can set the
8080 let's define a root
route uh it will take request Handler
with two arguments request and response
so I'm going to send the
response say hello
world now we need to listen the
application we need to set the
port for app I can say
Port here I can run a simple
message
listening on
Port I have to use backtick
here
here we also need to replace colon to
pactic now I can add variable which is
Port so when you run the application you
will get the error because we don't have
installed burn so I can install
burn actually we we did not install
Express we need to add the Express
package as a
dependency
it has installed Express so the error
should be gone now now we need to run
the project we can say burn server. we
don't need to write node server.
yes I didn't set any configuration for
TI script not yes config nothing
here app
is listening on port
8080 you can verify that go to the Local
Host colon
8080 now you can see the hello
world this is how the burn is powerful
and the fastest to build
application